my name is Devin Odell I'm a software
engineer at fastly I work on our core
caching infrastructure we're based on
top of varnish so that's sort of my
platform everyday personally I'm a
really big fan of performance work and
debugging work debugging mostly because
when you do performance work you have to
do a lot of debugging work so it's just
easier to be a fan of it because
otherwise your life so miserable I'm
also a pretty big Frank Zappa fan and
don't know if I'm a bigger Frank Zappa
fan or performance fan but I'm clearly a
little bit bigger than I was in that
picture anyway a lot of the time when
people add fastly give talks they're
talking about sort of our distributed
system the challenges coming with
implementing a you know large global
network distributed systems problems but
I'm gonna focus at something at a
smaller level so something that happens
in our points of presence our pops and
in fact even something that happens on
an individual machine level so as a
content delivery network what we do is
effectively caching content for our
customers and delivering it to our
customers users and doing that at a
massive scale and there's there's
problems with being able to do that at a
systems language level like see one of
these problems is as many of you
probably know sharing memory is really
hard to do and especially if you need to
do that across process concurrently so
on a cache node we may have many
processes and these processes are sort
of able to allocate and free memory from
their own private heaps and because
there's no real general-purpose way for
us to share these any data between these
heaps concurrently safely or really at
all because they're private heaps these
processes can't really communicate at
least not through memory directly and it
would be really great if we had some
kind of system to do that right because
then we could start off sort of problems
with things like cache eviction lists or
indexes of objects on SSDs or that kind
of
that could help processes help each
other complete tasks so we implemented a
concurrent allocator it's called micro
slab and it allows us to basically do
just this it's a shared state memory
allocator that works concurrently
between processes and the talk today is
sort of going to be an exploration about
sort of how you get from the idea of
doing this to making something that
performs predictably under a high
concurrent load so first off as you
might have guessed by the name microsnap
this is a slab allocator a slab
allocator is a class of memory allocator
that hands out fixed sized objects right
so we don't have the same problems with
slab allocators with fragmentation
because it's really easy we can just
sort of put objects back in and get them
out because they're all fixed size but
what's a slab well the slab is just some
contiguous section of memory that's
broken up into a bunch of these fixed
size objects and if we want to allocate
from this slab all we have to do is just
sort of you know what we want to do is
call our allocation routine oops and
apparently that's not gonna work
but we pulled objects off the front if
we want to free them we're gonna free
them back they're also going to the
front this looks like a stack it is a
stack it's also called a free list but
we're sort of looking at this from a
single process perspective so what
happens if we add concurrency into the
mix and and really the question that we
need to answer is how do we actually
reason about the correctness of our
allocator in the face of concurrency
well something that's really useful to
do is to sort of define a protocol so
even though we're not really like doing
sort of defining message passing
semantics or something we can think of
our allocator as a sort of protocol
where we have requests for objects that
receive responses containing objects we
also have requests to free objects back
onto the allocator and those free
requests are responded to when the free
completes and I think we probably should
all intuitively agree that a request
comes before a response but I'm going to
come
I didn't make that totally clear because
that's important that that's really a
constraint right and we have other
constraints that we can define on our
allocation protocol so for instance we
can't perform an allocation and have a
subsequent allocation return the same
object without having an interstitial
free and a similar pattern constraint
holds for freeing objects so how do we
describe this
well we describe this with execution
histories and in this particular case we
have processes a and be issuing
allocation requests and they both
receive responses these requests and
responses are interleaved but they do
have an order so the execution history
allows us to sort of think about the
particular ways that we can sort of
order the operations of our of our
software and how it's going to execute
now it should also be well maybe not
obvious but we can also permute these
execution histories so we could reorder
these execution execution lines in in
four factorial ways so we get 24
different particular execution histories
but not all of them are valid right so
for instance if we reorder so that
begets a response before its sentence
request that's breaks causality and
that's mind-bending and like we can't do
that so so we say that this has violated
our protocol so let's put it back so
these constraints that we've declared on
our protocol really help us better
reason about the correctness of it and
and it seems like it's providing us a
way to sort of talk about an execution
history that that can help us become
convinced that our protocol is correct
or that an implementation of it is
correct so what other constraints do we
need to put on this particular execution
history to sort of get some some better
feelings of correctness well the first
thing that we can do is we can constrain
the type of history that we're talking
about so an execution history allows
reorder
you know arbitrary elements and
arbitrary orders but we can we can talk
about sequential histories as well in a
sequential history is a history where
any requests from our protocol is
succeeded immediately by a response so
this is an atomic effectively operation
requests and responses then become
atomic within these execution histories
and that seems to be like kind of a
property that we were missing from our
execution history and if we want
concurrent access to our allocator
seems like atom isset e is something
that we need so what does this look like
well here we have requests and responses
and and their atomic which is maybe
easier to see if they're grouped like
this the previous execution history
obviously was not a sequential history
because the requests and responses were
interleaved and what this means is that
if we introduced sequential consistency
into our allocator we we now have a
constraint where no allocation can
happen with at the same time as another
allocation no free can happen at the
same time as another allocation so we
have this sort of ordering it seems of
events but notice that while we can't
enter leave our requests and responses
that all of these operations have to
complete atomically we can still reorder
them all with respect to themselves okay
and reordering request and response
pairs can still yield a valid sequential
history and so that I am talking about
reordering because what we're actually
allowed to reorder within history is
about to become really important so just
keep keep this reordering in mind but
first let's kind of look at some code
like what what is what is a stack
effectively look like what is our free
list going to look like well we're gonna
have an allocate and free interface the
allocation for a slab allocator is just
going to read the head of the stack it's
going to read the next element off of
the head and it's going to put that next
element as the new head of the stack
simple freeing we have an object we just
read the stack head that becomes
objects next element we make the stack
head the object that we're freeing so
what do we have to add to this to get
sequential consistency well we can just
lock right we can just put locks around
it and right that's great so lock based
synchronization is is nearly like the
canonical sort of a solution to shared
memory or sharing memory and
multiprocessor and multiprocessor
systems and they're easy to reason about
right because they serialize access to
the critical sections right the part in
between the lock and the unlock and this
serialization creates a sequential
behavior so that's cool let's let's take
a look actually at how a lock itself is
implemented right because it's useful to
understand the guarantees that the lock
makes and how it makes them so really
understand why the lock protects our
structure and the kind of lock that
we're gonna be talking about just
basically for simplicity purposes as a
spin lock and in particular we're going
to talk about a test and set spin lock
so the way that this lock works is that
it snapshots the state of the of the
mutex of the lock resource it sets the
state to locked and then it says what
was the state of the snapshot when I
read it if the state was locked
we didn't acquire the lock because it
was already locked right so we just spin
and we keep doing that as long as we
have seen that we didn't change the
state from unlocked to locked if the
previous state was unlocked we have
acquired the lock right so in that case
we just exit now in the case of
unlocking that's pretty simple all we
have to do set the state to unlocked
we're good so this is how an
implementation might look like in the C
language this code is actually sort of
simplified from concurrent the
concurrency ket library which provides a
number of really great interfaces to
concurrent data structures spin locks
and other things and this looks correct
right like this this basically looks
like the sort of flowchart that we just
looked at but how can we reason or
define the correctness of this
implementation formally well because an
atomic operation by
definition is individual indivisible any
atomic operations to our mutex to this M
variable right here are sequentially
consistent among themselves so there's a
couple things to notice about this one
is this sort of test and set operation
is it actually embedded in a larger
sequence of histories which is actually
entering the lock function and exiting
the lock function or trying to acquire
the lock and acquiring the lock and in
the case of multiple processes let's
imagine that that process be previously
held the lock write and process a is
trying to to acquire it well we we have
a stronger constraint actually than just
sequential history that we have to apply
to this because sequential histories
would allow us to reorder these
operations these these atomic lock
release or the store request response
and in process be an atomic lock acquire
in process a we can't do that because
that violates the guarantee of mutual
exclusion the lock is giving us in the
first place so if we've concluded that
out of the set of all execution
histories we have some subset of
sequentially consistent execution
histories it looks like we're even
moving towards a stricter subset of
those that satisfies some other
desirable property and that property is
linearize ability so linearizable
history is a sequential history but it
has an additional constraint on it that
requested response pairs cannot be
reordered with respect to each other and
linearize ability was actually defined
by the Herlihy twing paper that we saw a
few slides back so what about linearize
ability is actually better so this a tol
CH paper gives us a couple of properties
in particular linearizable linearize
ability is easier to verify formally and
this is because linearize ability has
two other properties number one it
applies to individual objects so this is
different from serializability and
database systems we're sort of the the
entire set of multiple operations on
multiple objects is gets the sort of
serial treatment whereas with linearize
ability individual operations on single
objects get the sort of serial treatment
this property of applying operations to
individual objects also makes
linearizable algorithms or linearizable
data structures composable so if I want
to apply a linearizable operation to
some object all of those operations
applied to the objects linearize as well
so given that sort of definition we
might think that there's only one
particular execution history here that's
valid which is maybe the one presented
but notice actually that we can sort of
still reorder the entry and exit of
these functions without breaking our
protocol and in fact we can even reorder
it a little bit more right so as long as
the unlock happens before the lock
this is linearizable now it seems that
there's something special about these
these atomic instructions why why do
they provide this linearizable this
linearizable
guarantee well in a paper that predates
me from Leslie Lamport he's talking
about in queueing and D queuing elements
from a concurrent list or concurrent
queue and what he's telling us is it's
actually sufficient for there to be an
atomic moment in in lock and unlock
operations we're sort of this
transaction appears to complete and and
this is the paper that sort of credited
for coining the toy the term
linearizable by the way but this atomic
moment in our functions is also called a
linearization point and prior to this
paper there was sort of an insistence
that sort of the entire function had to
be atomic so this this gives us a new
way of thinking about linearize ability
how we can apply it to objects so in our
functions that use this lock based
synchronization plan these these
linearizable moments are anywhere within
the locks critical section and with
respect to our locking interface
it also has linearization points which
are the atomic operations changing the
state of the mutex so now we have a
formal basis for understanding our lock
and understanding its correctness how
does this perform right at the beginning
I said you know we sort of want an
alligator to perform well and that makes
sense because you know performance
matters but what do I actually mean by
performance because that's also a really
nebulous term right so what I mean is
that we get some decent throughput but
we also get predictable throughput with
concurrent load and that's really hard
to do so does our locking strategy
provide that well with so this graph is
showing the number average number of
acquisitions per second well not
acquisitions but lock allocate free
unlock operations per second across you
know sort of threads on the x-axis and
and the test was run for 10 seconds so
although with no contention we sort of
complete and something like 18
nanoseconds as soon as we add one thread
contending and you could also think of
this as processes if you want our
throughput immediately drops by an order
of magnitude like a factor of 20 25
something like that and it continues to
degrade as we add more threads which is
maybe easier to see on this logarithmic
plot so we're crossing nearly four
orders of magnitude of throughput
degradation as we add contending threads
and this is going to actually put a
limit on how our allocator will behave
because these operations wrap sort of
the the stack mutation so recall that
this test and set algorithm the way that
it works is it reads the state and then
it writes a state
and then it tests a state effectively
well why do we write every time right
this seems kind of wasteful why are we
gonna go and write some value back to
memory every time through the loop if
the locks already unlocked why are we
wasting these rights and sending them
back to memory well it smells like
something we can improve on and sure we
can so let's introduce this sort of
inner loop and instead of every time we
go through our lock acquisition trying
to set it to lock every time through we
have an inner loop that if it was locked
we just wait for it to be locked so
we're not doing any rights anymore right
we're just reading this memory now but
at first blush this this kind of feels
incorrect right because what if we've
got you know a thousand threads or
processes in here and aren't they all
going to wake up and see that the mutex
is unlocked and then race sure they are
and and this is a race condition right a
race condition simply said is a sort of
a system behavior where the output were
behavior of the system is dependent on
sort of the sequence or timing of
uncontrollable events like scheduling
maybe so can they be safe yeah we
linearize at this atomic test and set
that provides us a guaranteed global
order of operations on this mutex so
race conditions really only become bugs
when they happen out of the order that
we intended with respect to our protocol
and thinking about race conditions in
this way can maybe help us get some
additional throughput out of our lock
and later we'll see how it can also help
us get even even more predictable
throughput because if we actually look
at the performance it's a little better
but it's not that much better and more
importantly it's still not predictable
so let's try another trick let's add
some some local state right so if we
implement some exponential back-off now
we're not sharing any memory but we
might think this is bad for another
reason right maybe we're
oversleep right maybe the lock is
unlocked halfway through our back off
and then we're gonna sleep for too long
right is is is that bad is that gonna
happen well no actually this turns out
to be a pretty decent way to get
additional throughput out of our spin
lock however we still have this like
kink in the graph it basically x equals
two right and that's depressing
we could probably keep trying like every
trick in the book on our locks but
really what it looks like is we're just
changing a coefficient in exponential
decay right and in order to understand
why let's we're going to talk about
something called a progress guarantee so
let's say we've got two processes and
some spin lock that's available to both
so we have the first process that enters
the function it switches the state to
locked and then it exits the function so
now it's within its critical section
somewhere maybe so now our next thread
or next process comes in it tries to
grab the lock but it can't so it's
spinning and it's not making progress so
there is actually no progress guarantee
being made in this system because the
first process is not under any
obligation ever to release the lock
there's nothing about a locking protocol
that defines win and unlock must happen
so furthermore our second process has no
choice but to wait until the unlock
happens before it can make progress
so in our total system we have no
progress being made so that's bad so
maybe we should have look into something
that that gives us system progress so we
can talk about one thing which is lock
freedom and that defines a system where
given contention on some resource at
least one thread or process will make
progress at any particular contended
moment so you you get this sort of
system-wide throughput guarantee
so maybe maybe we want to use that
solution and maybe we want to embed that
into our data structure instead of just
you know simply using locks around these
sort of sections that clearly need
protection to prevent you know
concurrent access to this from from
becoming a race condition that does
happen out of order so this is where non
blocking algorithms come in so lock
freedom is a class of non blocking
algorithm like I said where we guarantee
progress of one thread at least and and
it seems like that this might be
something that actually provides some of
the predictability that we're looking
for so how do we implement something
like this well we're not tied to test
and set processors and most modern
processors in fact all commodity
processors for machines that I'm aware
of that people are using in data centers
and most mobile devices all support
compare-and-swap as well as a number of
other atomic read-modify-write
operations so what does compare-and-swap
do well given some value and some place
in memory what we're gonna try to do is
compare these values if they're not
equal we just return false if they are
equal we additionally have a new value
and we're going to try to swap that in
to the destination and if we do that we
return true and now the processor is
providing us also an atomic interface to
this and therefore we can also use it
for linearizing so if we apply this to
the allocator we get something like this
right up at the top here you can see
sort of a stack of or the state of the
stack so if we were executing here we
would as before read sort of the state
of our stack the variables a and B here
or sort of corresponding to a and B
elements in the stack up there and the
next thing that we're gonna do is we're
gonna try to swap B to be the head of
the stack using this compare and swap
operation so if we succeeded we've
acquired a and
is the new head of the stack right that
makes sense but what if this
compare-and-swap returns false well if
we go back to sort of this color-coded
example if if it returned false then
then we know what happened right either
well period the head was changed right
somewhere in in between our read of the
head and our attempt to compare and swap
that seems like a race so so what could
have happened well we could have had
some process free and now we have a new
element at the front of the stack
maybe another allocation happened and a
got pulled off of the stack so this
seems like really racy behavior but
again because of the linearization point
provided by our atomic compare-and-swap
we we are guaranteed in this case that
the the state we've observed will be
consistent the a is no longer there
we're gonna retry so what about free
well free is actually simpler because we
only have an object we read the head you
know it's the same thing we try to swap
the new object into the head atomically
if we can't you know we had another one
of these classes of race conditions
happen and we just retry right
effectively this compare-and-swap is
letting us detect a state change and
retry so now this is great right we've
got this concurrent stack and the stack
is we can treat it like a free list so
it's it's our allocator right let's just
race a bunch of cards against it right
we've just been already seen like this
is concurrent safe right so let's
imagine that we have this this process
and it goes in and it reads everything
it reads the front of the the slab head
it's going to read the next element and
it's going to stop executing before it
gets to the compare-and-swap
because that's actually a thing that
happens all the time in the meanwhile we
have another process that comes in and
it's got some execution time so it's
going to go ahead and allocate and a
comes off of the head of the slab so
let's play this game again let's take
another process and it's going to come
in and this process is going to allocate
and B is now off of the slab so we still
haven't executed our compare-and-swap
yet but it's fine because now C is the
head so we'll just retry if we were to
execute right now but instead of doing
that let's say that now our second
process decides that it's done with
object that it got and it's gonna go
ahead and put it back okay so now we can
see we read a was the stack head we read
B was the next element but now the state
of our stack has changed from under us
and this is no longer true so let's
finally do our compare and swap
operation well we got a but now B's back
in the list right and that violates the
semantics of our alligator protocol so
this is actually a classic concurrency
bug and it's called the ABA problem but
it's it's only a problem for us because
of our workload right we've defined that
we need to have multiple concurrent
effectively readers and writers to our
allocation pool depending on your
workload you may not actually need to
solve this problem depending on sort of
the amount of state that you care about
from your structure and the number of
concurrent processes that you have on
either side of maybe the push or pop
operation or whatever other operations
you might have on another similar
structure so solving this problem costs
definitely time overhead it can also
cost memory overhead
the way that we're going to solve it
does so it's definitely something to
keep in mind as to whether you can
change your workload to one that doesn't
have to solve it for our purposes as we
do so what we're going to do is we're
going to add a generation on to our
stack and this is just like a counter
and it's basically going to count the
number of allocations that happened
right
this is providing additional state into
our structure that we can use to check
the validity of our assumptions based on
our snapshot at the beginning so by
introducing this counter if we're
checking it we can we can pop a off the
stack and then we can push B in push a
and then we can't actually ever have a
be a happened because the pop would have
incremented the generation counter from
anybody who had read it the first time
so what does this look like in code well
instead of using our objects like we
used to have object pointer a B up here
now we're representing this sort of
entire slab head and the reason that we
have to do this is now we're comparing
to two words of memory that are side by
side it's important to note that these
do actually have to be contiguous the
the head pointer and the generation
counter and that's because this deck has
this double wide calves
it's a compare and swap operation but it
works over to two words of memory or two
double words of memory in the case of
you know a 64-bit system but whatever I
guess it depends on how you define word
so this solves the problem because of
the reasons that I I mentioned
previously but another thing to point
out here is that we're reading the
generation before the head and that's
actually super important not actually
for our allocator but I want to point it
out because if you go and you start
writing your own concurrent data
structures this becomes very important
so uniqueness is also a property of our
allocator and that's implied by the sort
of you can't allocate the same thing
twice and you can't free the same thing
twice right that implies a uniqueness of
objects in the system so any object that
you allocate is distinct from any other
object in a general-purpose stack that's
not necessarily true we might have
element a that we can push on to the
stack 50 million times and it's fine
right if we do have that case we could
have a case where a concurrent reader
from the stack or somebody trying to pop
reads a as the stack head somebody else
pushes another a onto the stack and then
we read the generation counter right so
now we see a at the front and we have
the latest generation counter so we're
going to mutate our stack again and it's
going to be the wrong state so reading
the generation counter first solves that
because we're guaranteed that if any
other operations happen the generation
counter will be different the next time
or when we actually operate our
compare-and-swap
do we have to do the same thing for free
well no free stays the same and it
this is really because free only depends
on the stack head first eight right the
reason that we need to do this
generation counter the reason that ABA
becomes a problem for us
really is because we read the stack head
we read the next element and that joint
state that that multi-level state is
effectively what's coming back and
biting us and causing us or combined
with our workload as I said coming back
and biting us into cause the ABA problem
okay
well it turns out that that's actually
all of the problems because I'm not
going to talk about cache coherence your
memory ordering in this talk so that's
all basically the race conditions that
we're going to see here so we've we've
solved this problem now we have a
correct concurrent lock free slab
allocator okay so what is the throughput
look like that's great that's
predictable right we have the this is
the same test but with our concurrent
allocator we see that as we increase
contention in some cases we're getting
even better throughput right it looks
linear it definitely looks linear on the
logarithmic plot but why is this right
like what what is it about this property
of lock freedom that that's really
helping us out so much well to do that
we need to look at something other than
throughput like throughputs great but it
doesn't tell you the whole story and in
particular we need to look at latency
plots okay so this is a min Max and 25th
to 75th quartiles box and whisker plots
of our testin testin set lock that was
the the test and set with the the nested
loop and what we see is that sort of in
the general case up to 75th percentile
we've got pretty reasonable latency but
from 75th to max value we've got this
just enormous variation it's
unpredictable and this is because of the
lack of progress guarantee from the lock
you you aren't guaranteed to make
progress and this introduces jitter
additionally it introduces a queuing
effect into the system so if you're
familiar with littles law that could
sort of explain this this jitter and
latency it takes your system out of a
stable State
I should also mention that I have also
skimmed the top 1% off of these numbers
to you know just account for any like
huge amount of system jitter that might
have been introduced and it's get off of
all of these plots I haven't talked
about pthreads a lot I suspect that a
number of people are using P threads for
reasons that have to do with having more
threads than you have cores in the
system which is a good case for not
using spin locks in fact but what we see
here is that we actually have
significant variance in distribution
from our twenty-fifth to 75th percentile
as well and we're also still in the same
order of magnitude on our y-axis here so
when we look at our exponential back-off
spinlock in general it seems fine but we
still at from from 75th percentile to
max we still have all of this jitter all
of this variance even though we've we've
decreased latency by an order of
magnitude so this decrease in latency is
actually the only thing that is giving
our tests and sets pinlock additional
throughput and this comes back back to
littles law right which says that the
number of outstanding items in a queuing
system in average outstanding items in a
queueing system is equal to the arrival
rate of new requests so contention on
the log rate plus the time it takes to
service a request so latency of the lock
because we were able to reduce the
latency in our exponential back-off
spinlock that's the only reason that we
got the throughput but because of the
queuing effect of locks that is why our
throughput still remains unpredictable
under high contention so finally let's
look at our latency four are concurrent
allocator that looks really good right
that is predictable right we're two
orders of magnitude town.the the
deviation between men and max is still
in the same order of magnitude
everything looks really good this is
what we need right under under
contention actually it performed or
under no contention it performed worse
I'd be happy to talk about that
afterwards if you're interested but as
we add contention we see that we still
get this very predictable latency and
that gives us our throughput again this
is that coupled with the progress
guarantee gives us the throughput
consistency as we add contention on the
structure so takeaways well one thing
that I really want to drive home because
I think maybe I didn't do it enough is
that racing processes with each other
it's not only like common when when
we're addressing throughput and latency
issues in our software it actually is
kind of a crucial part of designing
non-blocking algorithms it's a crucial
part of trying to improve throughput in
perhaps our locking functions where we
see that doing something that reduces
latency can help us increase throughput
by by racing these processes in a way
that's friendlier to the system and and
furthermore we can do that safely
because our systems provide us with
these atomic read-modify-write
primitives like test and set like
compare and compare and swap fetch and
fee you know whatever operation you want
to do and and these linearization points
provide us with a total globally
observable order between all processes
in the system that they all agree on all
the time because it linearizes good so
that's a that's we're wrapping it up I
definitely did not cover all of the
things about a slab allocator or
performance things that you want to keep
in mind in particular per thread slabs
what to do when your slab is out of
memory stealing from elsewhere that kind
of stuff if you're interested in this
code or using this in your systems
definitely check check out use lab bio
which right now is just redirecting to
our github page we've open sourced this
and it's under the Apache 2 license also
before I wrap up I want to thank my
colleague Nathan Taylor so he actually
presented this talk at
Serg yesterday but the conferences were
happening concurrently so I couldn't be
at both I also really can't overstate
how much he helped both with content and
you know teasing out bugs and some of
the testing stuff and you know giving
these slides a consistent total order so
that's all I've got for you thank you
for coming if you've got questions I
think there's only two minutes left so
I'm gonna head out to the fastly booth
that's just down the hall so feel free
to come see me and ask questions there
and thank you for coming
[Applause]